well I'm joined Now by Brian Cox Brown
great to see you here in New York you
have a place so you spend a lot of time
here well my fam all my my boys are here
they're I I would they're American so
they have to be you know my youngest is
currently in Thailand and is about to go
Emerson College and my eldest of the
second family he's at the Atlantic
theater school and he's now directing a
project for the summer so uh my wife's
here so but I'm about to go back to
England because I'm going to be doing
work for me with your kids have you got
the succession sorted yes yes they get
nothing
the one thing I've learned is don't give
them anything
it's quite interesting actually because
that's become quite a debate where a lot
of people think of you give the kids
nothing others take of you give them
something others spoiled and
ridiculously how have you actually been
as a father in that regard
I I think I'm fair I I think that you
know it's you know I've been a father of
different Financial stages in my life
you know I mean there's a time when I
was you know I had a very my first wife
was very smart with money so I was quite
good at that uh we're not so smart with
money on this side but we're doing much
better I actually on my on my WhatsApp
chat uh with my three sons in their 20s
I often send them Logan Roy gifts as as
responses to their various observations
about what I should be doing to help
them I I love the way you say
observation I mean their needs yes
demands that's exactly let me ask you I
mean post succession
is it a weird feeling when you come out
of something that's so iconic so
successful why is a bit weird I mean the
problem is that uh I can't go anywhere
now I mean I I used to Pride my
anonymity but it's gone even here in New
York was they sort of used to oh yeah I
mean I go wherever I go somebody will
come up and say Hey can I have a picture
or can you tell me uh you know what you
know and and I go okay and you can you
can and it's the best thing to say to
somebody because in a way you mean it
this is the most famous you've ever been
in your life yeah I I think so and do
you like that I mean is it well
intoxicating but also a little bit
intimidating it has it it it's a sort of
what is it how do I describe it
it's a sort of
it's all right but it's also sometimes
gets a little bit over much you know I
mean you know because people are so
they're so into the show I mean it's
just incredible it's kind of weird when
I went to China I was in China recently
and I thought oh this is great you know
nobody will be nobody will know the show
it lasted a day really a day even there
Logan Royal and that suddenly all these
kids
[Laughter]
and you know it's kind of strange and I
thought oh God you know but I mean
people are always I have to say people
are always very nice they're always very
graceful and you get the odd kind of
your budgie guy who comes in or says you
know and you go no coolant and I've
learned the one thing I have to I've
learned
and I've never been good at this is
saying no I've had to learn how to say
no on occasion where are your limits
well my limits you want to just gets too
much you know or when it's when we're in
a particular area like getting off a
plane and somebody says can I and I'm
going well there's a lot of other people
if I start giving you I know the world
and his wife is going to start coming up
and wanting a photograph and I'm never
going to get to baggage
the the ending of succession the final
season I gotta be honest with you when
they killed you off I was incredibly
disappointed I thought it was you're not
alone peers well and I read then that
you were well I was I mean
I I wasn't really disappointed I mean I
trust Jesse Armstrong implicitly and
it's his decision and I want not to go
with his decision and that was fine I
understood it uh I think personally it
was a little quick I think I think they
could have given it but I think they
wanted that Sudden Impact which is what
it got yeah you know and that amazing
episode which I never watched by the way
you've never seen it no really why
well the idea of watching myself dying
on a on a plane is not merely my idea of
fun you know it's not something I really
want to take on board you know oh you
know I just watched myself die a lot
so dramatic and so good and I was so
overwhelmed by my dad and bollocks to
that
I know I know you know I mean it just
you just go yeah you know and people
kept somebody would say did you watch
the episode I said no why not it's a
great episode I said I'm sure it's a
great episode but I no I there's no way
that I'm going to watch myself an ear or
a bit Eminem lying on a you know on a
copper on a plane you know funny enough
I watched it and after that the next few
episodes it began to lose me because you
weren't there because Logan Roy was no
longer part of it I began to lose
interest and I tweeted to that effect
and then got a whole mail stream of
response from people and I if you'll
probably hate this but I got back into
it when your coffin appeared in the in
the funeral scene yeah yeah because
suddenly you were back and then of
course there were some amazing
performances but the other character is
with them responding because you were
there again yeah I felt that quite
viscerally as a as a fan of the show
yeah I mean yeah I was I mean that was
also a very funny thing that happened
because they were worried about the
funeral and they kept saying you know uh
you know we we don't want to give it
away we've got to keep it you know so
they said we'll shoot you I will do a
scene that we won't use and we'll call
you on the day so you can come up and do
the scene and I went oh okay
so I'm driving driving up to do this
scene and I get the call and say oh we
don't need you
I said oh no we can't we haven't got
time to shoot that scene I said okay and
then I said to the driver Joe I said
we're going I said let's go I said
because I know he's shooting his eggs
when I get there there'll be Paparazzi
and they'll want you know they'll want
to know
and that's what happened I I arrived and
there I was you know Logan dress and uh
I fooled them that oh well it's not his
funeral yeah but if I hadn't been there
they would have known they would have
known it would have been blown yeah when
it was over
really over in the last episode aired
and that's the end of succession what
were your honest feelings about that
well I my honest feelings is I'm I was
incredibly proud to be part of such a
an extraordinary show and really uh kind
of groundbreaking in many ways because
it's a satire and it's brilliantly
written mainly by British writers who
know how to do that thing of edge they
get that sense of Edge and certainly
Jesse does and I trusted them completely
I mean one could quarrel and say you
know it's all I mean there's all I mean
you get all kinds of things which are
stupid like sensibly oh I've been
rejected because I'm they're killing me
off but of course it's called succession
yes you know he's got to go sometimes
he didn't make it I hate to ask you this
because it sounds a bit morbid but when
you go through your own death in a drama
like that as an actor does it make you
think more about dying uh
I've always thought about dying I mean
yeah I mean you know I lost my father
when I was eight so death has always
been kind of omnipresent in my life so
I'm and I've lost you know my sister my
elder sister just passed away in
February so I I'd experienced that and
ironically you know Logan's death is
quite funny because I was never there I
mean I I was never on that plane right
that was somebody else lying there was
it yeah
it was just a lion a lion it was a lion
not a standard it was a lion and my lion
was there and and then I had to come up
because they wanted to shoot my ear now
it could have been anybody's ear you
know I mean because you know you want to
shoot my ear I said yeah I said I lied
and that was after the it was way after
the funeral I came back like I mean the
funeral was that was episode when the
death was episode three and I came back
to do something when they were filming
in episode six and I just lay there and
they shot my ear and then I went
it was a bit ridiculous to be honest
with you how do you follow something
like succession
Christ knows
I mean you know how do I follow someone
is this what your bank manager is asking
exactly exactly they're all going and
now what you know uh I mean I'm going
back to the theater yeah I'm going to do
this playback and then in the New Year
I'm going to go into the West End and do
long Dead's journey tonight right which
I'm gonna do at the Windham theater with
the brilliant Jeremy Herron and the
wonderful Patricia Clarkson who's a
wonderful American actress who I've long
admired so I'm doing that it's a play
I've always wanted to do and I was
planning to do that anyway I was
planning to go back to the theater just
to sort of
see if I can still land lines you know
that's my biggest nervous thing whether
I'm able to still land so yeah and uh
because he's pretty arduous there to
work oh yes especially in Britain I mean
people American actors have told me they
have huge respect for the art of
American of British acting and because
of the theater trade yeah but it's
really it's grueling but it's how we're
it's it's you know it's um mother's milk
really it's what we do that's how we you
know that's where we come from you know
we go through I mean I was a kid I
always wanted I loved the movies but
when I discovered the theater there's no
going back because the theater is so
extraordinary and it's and we are such a
theater-based culture you know whereas
America is a cinema-based culture yeah
you know and it's always interesting
about that because it's it's very
interesting egalitarian societies create
Cinema like uh France like America you
know feudal societies they create
theater right and everybody keeps in
their place
and I'm not allowed to go beyond that
place could you imagine retiring I know
me yes or never no no no I don't believe
in that no I'll go on to our drop would
you would your dream be in in
mid-performance no no no no might no be
a sort of wind down I think slowly I
think eventually the the dementia will
get me
I think I think I'll be and then it'll
be nice to be able to say well I can't
do it anymore I've got it I'm hoping
that I can keep dementia at Bay for a
bit longer I'm still you know I'm not
old just spring chicken I'm a spring
look at me I look quite well you do it
very well actually I know you do look
very well I know I think I look amazing
for my age
I'm 77. are you really yeah you look
great I know yeah I go to the gym
regularly I still got this problem but I
go to the gym and I pump on or I do yeah
yeah yeah how often do you do that uh
well I try and do it I've been doing it
every day since I've come back wow and
I'm going to join a gym when I go to the
go to London and do it more regularly I
mean I just couldn't find a gym in
London but I there was one there that I
think I'm going to go back so yeah I
mean it's necessary and it's all about
muscle too because you know I mean I
look at people running and I go no no
don't run no I totally agree you know
running is all your limbs oh yeah I mean
everybody people you know and you see
these guys who are hailing hearty age 52
and by the time they're 56 they're gone
and I just go stupid does it help with
your anger management about global six
right now uh yes it adds to it
you know it makes me more and more it
gives me uh somewhere to get my vent I
mean I shouldn't think it's difficult
because both in the United States and in
the UK I mean there's a lot of
Mayhem going down let's talk I would say
there's a lot of crap going down quite
frankly I was going to use that word
let's talk about America first but it
does seem extraordinary that we're
reaching a position where potentially
the next election is Biden V Trump again
in a population of 320 million people
yeah well it's
I have to be careful what I say you know
because I am an American citizen I'm a
dual citizen uh my my boys are American
citizen but
well it hasn't been particularly good in
the UK either no no I'm going to come to
that we'll come into it start with
America so it's all pretty horrible it's
all pretty horrible really and it's been
really I think
living under that four years was such a
strain I mean it really was and we were
here I mean I'm convinced that's I think
Jesse and the writers got really
exhausted by that you know it was very
interesting because on the first of
first read-through of the show
when we shot the first pilot was the day
that Trump was elected was it really
yeah and everybody was going back to see
Trump well to see uh Hillary elected and
I knew I was here I was here and it
wasn't extraordinary walking around
Manhattan when it was known that Trump
had won it was eerily quiet yeah people
were openly crying in the spring it was
extraordinary to watch no I know it was
it was not a good time and the
ramifications of that have been pretty
horrendous really are things worse now
or is our perception of Life worse
because of things like social media
inflaming everything well I think I
don't think social media helps
it hinders rather than helps and I think
it points up
too readily inadequacies that we can
actually and the whole woke well we've
talked about this before the whole work
culture I think is truly awful and the
shaming culture and the shaming culture
which I really feel quite strong this
incessant need to shame yeah and bury
people like I don't know where it comes
from I don't know who's who are the
Arbiters of these this shaming right and
it's very hard to pin them down and it
turns out it's usually a bunch of
Millennials right and who and who gave
them the Halos I don't know I mean they
think it's children well I mean I
suppose in a way they're probably saying
well you've all screwed it up so we may
as well do something about it but it's
it's from the wrong principle it's the
wrong it comes from their own place when
you see Biden he's only a little bit
older than you I know when you see when
Iran yes he did actually you can't
anymore no no Barry walks but I mean
when you when you see him you know
falling over and tripping and all the
verbal gaps and so on like I say I mean
you don't do that and you're observative
so funny I was at the doctors this
morning and they kept saying do you have
to help yourself up when you stand you
know are you able to how can you deal
with the curb I was being asked this
question I said this is like I'm pumping
big weights I can move a girl but it's
very funny I watched the Indiana Jones
the other day which is I loved I thought
it was great I mean some people a bit
like that but I actually because I love
Harrison Ford yeah and they did this
amazing makeup thing without his info
but the only thing they couldn't do was
Harrison on stairs because all of us
even I on stairs are nervous and we are
very over cautious on the stairs and
there's a signature it's a younger
Harrison and it's all going well and
then suddenly for a few seconds he has
to descend the stairs and itches
okay you're going back to the UK to do
this this production in bath and then
and moving to the West End
we've had a nightmare haven't we Boris
Johnson the chaos Liz truss not
outlasting a lettuce uh Rishi soon act
certainly he's brought a little bit of
decency back I think in terms of the
weekend Ducks himself but the Tories
seem in big trouble Nicholas sturgeon of
course four starred in Scotland and then
being arrested and so on I think that's
a bit of a Witch Hunt quite honestly do
you I do I really do I think that she's
been made a scapegoat there's something
going on there which is you know she's
been arrested why would she be arrested
well in connection with the financial
and propriety charges against asthma
yeah but it's but but they were all
dropped they lasted you know it's like
after two hours they were unarrested so
why did they arrest him in the first why
didn't they question whether they're
arresting them I mean all of it's so
dodgy quite honestly I mean you know who
would who would have it in for to that
degree do you think
it's hard to know it really is hard to
know but I do think that there's a real
there was a real worry about it and
especially the vulnerability of the
Tories at the moment but also the
vulnerability of the labor party I mean
I know kids time it doesn't want to have
anything to do with uh with uh you know
Independence Scottish independence he
really is absolutely Ghana but you see I
think what's interesting in in the UK is
the work that somebody Andy like Andy
Burnham was doing in Manchester yeah how
that is really working and how those
cities like Liverpool and Manchester
really and all you have to do is join
them up and suddenly you've got a kind
of autonomous group that are really con
you know being incredible but uh why is
this such a paucity of Leaders with a
really Fierce moral compass a capability
to bring people with them and to really
affect change well I think the the
problem is that they get marginalized
you know I mean I think Andy Burnham is
a case in point I mean he's to me he's
the perfect leader of the labor party it
should be no question from my from my
point of view and he's done an amazing
job but of course he's he's sidelined
he's put into that bracket that they've
put him over there so they can almost
deal with them it's it's odd I mean ever
since I I did a film called hidden
agenda many many years ago and
discovered all about what was going on
with the Ross mcwherter
Harry NIV and of course mountbatten what
they were all part of those three guys
were part of something which was
a little fifth columnish you know I
think and and of course there were
horribly treated because they were
assassinated but again it's the soul
with secret society that that runs the
UK I mean there's a it's a very
secretive you know there is a series of
hidden agendas that are we don't really
see are you a cricket fan bruh I admire
it but I'm Scottish I know so who do you
want to win out of England and Australia
oh I like England to Wing really I went
to Scots wanted whoever beats
this idea that we do I mean I'm an
anglophile you see I'm my view
pierces I don't want to see I mean I
love England I love the United Kingdom
and in a way when you look at it you
look at the map and you see you know you
see Scotland England Wales Ireland
Northern Ireland and I've always thought
that really what we need is not a United
Kingdom we need a United Federation we
need a we need a situation where each
country is autonomous and they come
together as a group so that we we have
to understand our reality but at the
same time we want to be independent we
want to be make decisions for ourselves
we're grown-ups and when you know even
though we're five million in Scotland
and I think that this is where I this is
what gets me because it's so everybody's
so afraid of that and so afraid of
breaking that you know and I think the
United Kingdom to me is finished I
really do I do I do I feel that we
should have a United Federation we
should all be on equal footing and then
we come together for the for the need of
the Isles you know what the what we are
geographically and I think we'd get a
better Society there were a few stories
recently where I actually immediately
thought of you yeah and thought I could
almost hear the steam coming out of your
ears one was that there's a new theater
production of The Sound of Music where
there are literally warnings to
audiences because they say the musical
touches on Nazi Germany and the
annexation of Austria that an audience
now has to be warned about The Sound of
Music well this is what I mean this is
what I can't stand
I can't stand the way we want to rewrite
history I can't stand the way we don't
want to acknowledge history and it's so
important to acknowledge what our
history is because that is defines who
we are and where we've got to and
without an acknowledging history we are
screwed you're well and truly screwed
and I think we've not done that nearly
enough but all these trigger warnings
that people want to put now on Art
whether it's books poetry
films and theater Productions whatever
it may be
when do we get so sensitive so overly
offended are we or is it other people
deciding we ought to be I think it
really is about other people deciding we
ought to be I don't think we are I don't
know anyone and it goes to the Sound of
Music he needs to be told by the way
there are references to Nazi Germany I
mean ridiculous I I I find that I don't
I don't know where that's coming from I
really don't I want to know who's making
those I think it's a small number of
people they it gets whipped up by a sort
of very woke mob on social media before
we know it this becomes standard
practice then you start seeing all the
books having great chunks well you know
you we had the whole thing with Roald
Dahl yeah you know which is disgraceful
it's ridiculous it absolutely
disgraceful I mean Roald Dahl is a you
know he was a difficult man but he wrote
some amazing stuff but if the criteria
for canceling people or revisiting
everything they do was being difficult
you would wipe out almost every artist
of any note in history yeah they're all
a bit difficult
and you know and you go it's not on it's
just simply not on and it's the you see
it also comes from complete ignorance
it's a it's an ignorant state that
creates this sort of oh that that's bad
that's good yeah I mean it's ridiculous
to say of course you know that's what
happened the you know people escaped
that's what they did it's not in the
music that's what it's about yes on trap
family you know and uh you know we don't
need to be told oh that's just remind
you that's it and you might be upset and
then you might be upset I mean it's also
we have to acknowledge our history
constantly we have to know where we are
we have to know what we've done and how
we've got here and it's it's a bit of a
mess do we kick ourselves too much now
about the past in other words do we when
you look back I totally agree we need to
know about our history and we need to be
informed so we don't make the same
mistakes and so on but this can't
constant kind of self-abuse use about
the past the guilt trip that goes on
about things that happen two three
hundred years ago trying to transport
morality of today back Center I mean
like we we are now realizing for example
about the slave trade and how much we
were really involved in that you know
and I think that's quite a good thing to
to tell people well you know we were not
all pretty and clean on that one we were
pretty bad we also led the world out of
the slave trade we did at the same time
so that should be acknowledged as well
exactly the Wilberforce movement all of
that you know which is very important
but that's history and that's our
history and that's what we have to
acknowledge and if we don't acknowledge
that
then we we're living in Cloud Cuckoo
Land Michael Sheen recently said he says
that non-welsh actors playing Welsh
characters he found hard to accept
what do you think of that
well it depends I I don't find it hard
to exactly they can do the work I mean I
played naive Bevin you know I played Nye
Bevin I'm a Scott I played I was I
played a Welshman how was your Welsh
accent very good can we have a no I'm
not gonna I'm not a performing monkey
hello Brian
look you
so doesn't you see no problem it's like
Stanley Tucci on desert island discs uh
said straight actors should be free to
play gay role of course I played gay
roles have you yeah it was great I
always got it was great especially when
I went I used to in the old days I used
to get um upgraded because I played a
game really yes it was very useful and
it's you know I was oh Mr Cox would you
like to go on too well
it's the bottom line that actors by the
very definition of the word should just
be left to do any acting role yeah
that's what acting the moment you start
saying only this community can play
themselves in a movie you're kind of
limiting it you know I mean you know I'm
a great watch of Eternal classic movies
and you see the range of people doing
what they're doing and some of some of
it's outrageous but some of it's pretty
amazing you know I mean John Ford doing
how green was my valley you know with a
sort of mixture of Irish and you know
celt actors because we're all the world
in the Scots and the Irish are killed of
course so we really are similar and we
know we are we our culture is exactly
the same you know I I don't agree with
Michael and I don't believe you know I
don't believe in having I know I mean if
a Scottish person if a non-scotish
person can do the Scottish thing I'll
buy it so if I was to suddenly take up
acting and play William Wallace you'd be
fine with that if you weren't any good
I mean if you were I would
certainly
don't go on the bombshell great to catch
up with you love it really I really
appreciate it and best of luck with your
Productions back in the UK good to see
you